bonjour à laon père merci de répondre à
nos questions en direct sur arte france
selon le land 7 le risque de mortalité
supérieur de 34 à 45 % chez les malades
de attendu qu'ovide qui prennent de
lecture roxy chloroquine ou de la
chloroquine à marseille sur 4000
patients la mortalité est de 0 5% selon
le professeur didier rahout qui croire
il faut sortir de cette polémique
j'ai l'impression d'assister à un match
de foot
un match de foot où il ya des clans
entre entre telle équipe et l équipe et
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement se
se conduit en oligan en systématiquement
en ostracisant un professeur de renom
qui fait ce raout et j'ai bien vu cette
étude je suis parlementaire mais je suis
surtout médecin c'est mon métier
cette étude les fêtes sur 600 hôpitaux
dans le monde il ya aucun nom des
hôpitaux dans les annexes
c'est une étude qui n'est pas randomisés
c'est une étude qui est fake et colas
ionnaires et c'est une étude qui est
fait sur des patients hospitalisés alors
que le professeur out a toujours dit il
faut dépister isolés et traités
le gouvernement français lui dit il faut
dépister isolé et tracé c'est que
différentes et en tant que médecin il
est important de traiter hydroxy
chloroquine et l'association avec le zii
trop max l'azithromycine c'est un
traitement qui coûte 14 euros
qu'on donne aux débuts de la de la
maladie en tant qu radiologue j'ai
beaucoup de mes confrères qui ont été
contaminés par ce qu'ils étaient comme
les urgentistes au au devant de cette
maladie parce que les scanners étaient
les premiers tests des premiers tests
efficaces soient nettoyées justement
vous êtes médecin un médecin radiologue
quand un de vos confrères médecins
médecins de ville vous dit qu'il ne peut
pas prescrire de traitement contre le
virus selon lui dit quoi gr le olivier
vers en notre ministre a fait un décret
le décret le 25 et 26 mars
pour réserver hydroxy chloroquine à
l'hôpital alors que l'hydroxyde
chloroquine associé au max doit être
prescrits avant et à l'hôpital si on
attend d'elle à l'hôpital c'est trop
tard
lyderic l'horripile el cheikh elle sert
à baisser la charge virale
justement vous parlez de cela sur le
professeur raout les de roxy chloroquine
et efficace au début de l'infection du
comité est ce que vous avez dit sur les
deux premiers jours pour faire baisser
la charge virale était importante alors
que le traitement était jusque-là près
présent utiliser en tout cas dans les
cas graves à l'hôpital donc lorsque la
charge virale est plus faible
finalement la question est-ce que c'est
pas celle ci parce que le curseur du
débat n'est pas placé au bon endroit est
ce que finalement ce n'est pas une
question des stades de la maladie voire
de profil du patient
cette étude elle ne répond pas du tout
aux critères du professeur 1 août
au contraire elle confirme ce que dit le
professeur out
il dit que la chloroquine hydroxyque
lockheed tel est inutile quand le
patient est en salle de réanimation
parce que quand ils en salle de
réanimation et se battre bien au scanner
le patient il va mourir d'embolie
pulmonaire c'est à dire que les soldats
les haines entre les alvéoles sont
pleines de thrombus donc de caillots
donc le patient il en train de mourir
par pas par une insuffisance
respiratoire due à une sécrétion
bronchique
parce que les poumons ne sont plus
irrigué donc le problème de l'hôpital
c'est un autre problème
il faut éviter que les patients à
l'hôpital
est ce que veulent les patients c'est
pas qu'on les renvoie chez eux avec du
doliprane où on est sûr que dans quinze
jours ils vont revenir à l'hôpital avec
une mallette beaucoup plus importante où
on va les mettre sous respirateur ou c
ou sous pour difficiel se donneront
compte en france
là vous parlez en tant que médecin
radiologue vous êtes également sénateur
les républicains
avec cette casquette selon vous est-ce
qu'il faut légiférer à l'échelle de la
france pour trancher définitivement ce
débat qui n'en finit pas parce que l'om
est au final fait des recommandations
simplement que la france n'a pas
toujours suivi d'ailleurs sur les tests
par exemple l'attitude a été ce pas
regardez regardez la liste des gens la
liste des gens qui ont écrit cette étude
ils sont il ya huit personnes qui sont
en conflit d'intérêts et même le le
rédacteur en chef de la revue lancet pts
il s'appelle ocha horton dit que la
majorité maintenant la moitié des études
sont faux c'est parce qu'un flux et des
affichages et d'études avec des
échantillons réduite des familles
des analyses préliminaires validé de
conflit d'intérêts avec l'obsession de
sueur dessus de suivre les tendances
d'importance doute est à la mode et la
science a pris le mauvais tournant vers
les ténèbres c'est le rédacteur en chef
de lens est le problème c'est que
maintenant la publication la publication
littéraire scientifique elle est soumise
maintenant à l'argent des dés de
l'industrie pharmaceutique
alors tous les genres en cause de la big
pharma bien sûr faisons confié bien sûr
faisons confiance
le professeur haouzi là on a une
opposition entre une site officiel ouah
gouvernementale qui interdit qui
interdit la chloroquine et qui prescrit
du doliprane et une médecine empirique
incarnée par didier rahout qui est on
l'a vu pendant le les deux mois
précédents où les gens regardaient leurs
écrans et voyait s'affronter un
gouvernement qui a accumulé les erreurs
face à un professeur de médecine qui
étaient rassurants qui proposait un
protocole simple économique et
disponible je peux vous dire que mes
confrères qui ont été malades qui ont eu
le colis qui ont pris leadership
neurones qui associé à des macrolides et
souvent à 10 anticoagulant débats ils
sont toujours là merci
et ça c'est ça qui est important merci
c'est bon de l'afar merci alors ouvert
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes médecin
radiologue et sénateurs les républicains
de la côte d'or